je vois des chiffres qui circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux sur le montant de
rémunération des ministres qui sont
totalement faux rémunération les
totalement transparente c'est 7450 euros
net par mois une fois les impôts déduits
j'ai une famille G4 enfants je fais mes
courses je paye mon alimentation et
c'est bien normal contrairement à ce qui
dit dans les réseaux sociaux je n'occupe
pas mon logement de fonction je paye mon
loyer voilà c'est des choses qui
méritent d'être dites dessert le plus
cher du monde il coûte officiellement
5850 euros le voici il s'agit d'une
glace dont les ingrédients sont tous
hors normes comme du saké d'exception
des feuilles d'or comestibles ainsi
qu'un iPhone 14 c'est un immeuble de 27
étages qui ne passe pas inaperçu hôtel
en or le Dolce Garden Lake est un 5
étoiles en plein cœur de la capitale
vietnamienne
il vient d'ouvrir ses portes plaquer or
forcément jusque là pas de tromperie sur
la marchandise tout semble en or
jusqu'au plafond dorure 24 carats lors
le plus pur mais ce qui fait vraiment
exploser son prix ce sont surtout
regardez c'est morceau de truffe blanche
Alba qui coûte 14000 euros le kilo si
vous ne connaissez pas la truffe blanche
c'est comme la truffe noire sauf qu'elle
rentre en boîte de nuit voici votre clé
un peu bling bling un petit air de Dubaï
au vietnamenseurs sont en or
et voici une des 244 chambres de
l'établissement vous lui rendors
interrupteur en or même la poignée
ou la salle de bain de la douche au
lavabo même la baignoire est en or
c'est aussi vrai pour les toilettes
plaqué or tu ne gagnes plus que Bruno Le
Maire ici
bravo
Raymond tu gagnes pas j'ai touché cette
somme là quand j'ai fait mes 13e mois
avec mon tarif quand je travaille sur
RTL et quand je travaille ici
alors quand tu veux vous savez on fait
un truc très simple vous voulez jouer à
celui-là
la semaine plus de couilles on va pas
jouer au jeu j'aime bien cette séquence
combien tu gagnes par mois disparu
depuis mercredi dernier à Pau la peluche
de la fille d'un restaurateur a été
retrouvé par trois jeunes originaire de
Tarbes suite à un appel sur les réseaux
sociaux après avoir mis la main sur le
doudou égaré ces derniers ont passé la
journée avec lui avant de le rendre à la
famille
si la récompense de la part du papa
était un an de Burger gratuit dans son
enseigne le trio a généreusement demandé
à ce que ces plats soient offerts au 200
prochains clients du restaurant les
adultes qui ont gardé leur doudou
[Applaudissements]
je me rends compte que j'ai beaucoup
mourir mourut
que j'ai beaucoup qu'est-ce que beaucoup
qu'est-ce que tu
m'a morue non marée
c'est où l'Occident
[Musique]
pour moi
le soleil il se lève ou au nord
[Rires]
mais pas une version 2.0 du célèbre
robot R2D2 dans Star Wars incroyable ah
c'est bien bravo félicitations on sent
une très grande complicité entre votre
robot et vous vous êtes ensemble depuis
longtemps
c'est ma vie je ne peux pas m'en séparer
ça ressemble à quoi
[Applaudissements]
tu le sais
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec voilà pour
m'éliminer je vous dis les gars va
falloir me passer dessus
qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être pénétrer
elle est sympa cette question
[Musique]
que ça fait des pénétrer oh là là si je
m'étais posé toutes ces questions
j'aurais jamais fait l'amour
quand ils sont à la Star Academy alors
ça ne me concerne pas bien sûr vous
étiez quel promo vous la quatrième
mais pour certains le sexe oh
mais la viande de Dieu un accordéon pour
passer concombre
que le Diable nous emporte on a rien
trouvé de faux
on a rien trouvé de je voudrais en fait
sur là les papiers les feuilles que vous
me dessiniez un sexe féminin maintenant
allez-y tout de suite dans la largeur
[Rires]
avoir des gazons publics ça nous est
tous déjà arrivé et c'est souvent
honteux
mais dernièrement face au PG malodorant
de son directeur commercial une
entreprise après une grande décision
licenciée ce salarié pour justifier son
licenciement la société lui a notamment
reproché son comportement son manque
d'hygiène et d'avoir laissé les
toilettes dans un état déplorable la
femme de ménage a été choquée par
l'odeur nauséabonde et votre impolitesse
le directeur commercial aurait également
fait des remarques désobligeantes à l'un
de ses collègues à qui il aurait dit
qu'il avait pris du ventre par exemple
bonsoir avant d'émettre un gaz
malodorant en lançant je cite il fallait
que vous sortiez du bureau du coup j'ai
des gainé l'arme massive
intentionné au sensiblement pour gérer
ses collègues
effectivement attention
ce serait que une fois que les mecs
auraient des rapports sexuels avec une
femme ça les apaise et qu'ils arrêtent
d'être con qu'ils arrêtent voilà toutes
ces petites guéguères ces conneries en
fait ça les apaise